hey y'all it's andrew catch here and in
this
tuesday video we're not gonna be going
over this week's data set
instead i'm still um uh gonna release
some
pre-recorded videos so um for this video
i figured
i would go over um regularization with
neural networks
so i have a few examples of how to
basically
um prevent or try to reduce overfitting
in your model so
your neural network can learn for more
epochs
um and i wanted to give some examples
specifically
some like pretty basic regularization um
techniques
um using keras so we're just gonna be
using the imdb
data set which is like uh imdb reviews
with the uh sentiment so
we basically just loaded in do a
uh some tokenization so in this case
we're gonna do
um frequency and then i built a overfit
model so
just like looking at this model without
even looking at the actual fit history
we know that this model will quickly
overfit
because it's a very long or deep model
with a lot of layers and it's very wide
with a lot of nodes
so this model realistically would never
be really made
for this type of data set but i thought
it'd be a good model to show
or an example of overfitting so i just
did
atom for the optimizer binary cross
entropy because it's a sigmoid
activation or binary classification and
then i fit it
uh to 30 epochs with it with a batch
size of 32
and then i created a validation split
with 80 20.
and when you're looking at this chart of
the actual history um this chart
really shows how fast this model over
fits
um uh when you're coming from say like
um like traditional black box machine
learning you can see that
um the accuracy is increasing for the
training
the validation axi is basically the same
so you think that's fine however one
thing you need to look at is the actual
loss
so the losses the actual calculations of
the loss function
which is binary across entropy and this
is basically how this model is
learning the data or learning was the
patterns of the data
and it's just showing the actual
predictions
prediction metrics from the accuracy so
ideally what we want
is to minimize our loss with our with
our validation loss
okay and we want to do that for a long
time so that our model
will start uh we'll continue learning
more features in
um and uh learning about the data and
being able to predict correctly
so for the first like three uh epochs
the model basically already means the
overfit and we can see that
um the model the there's like a cross
section between the training validation
loss where our loss
is going to be expanding probably to
infinity whereas our training loss is
basically going to be
about going down to zero or approaching
zero and this is
an example of overfitting where we want
our loss to essentially
go down to zero like our training loss
and realistically when you're doing um
when you're training up a model
um the longer you run it for or the more
epochs you have
the loss the validation loss will go
down and then
kind of do a u-form world it'll go back
up and start overfitting
um one of the ways to basically
prevent overfitting with your model is
to just simply just make your model
smaller
so you can do it um two ways one by
reducing the amount of layers
and two reducing the width of your
layers
because these layers are adding um some
parameters
for the model to actually tune and more
parameters generally lead to overfitting
so for the first model that i created
um to actually regularize the previous
neural network is i basically
subtracted the amount of layers that we
used the traditional three layer neural
network and then also
subtracted the width of the model okay
and if i actually count the parameters
we actually removed
about um 24
million parameters and that's good right
so we reduce the amount of parameters
and we can see that kind of helped it a
little bit
because the the loss increases at a
slower rate
but it is still overfitting okay
but that's one way to to regularize your
model
um which is pretty straight forward i
think intuitively most people would kind
of think about that where
they want to build a smaller model first
and then start
to make it a little bit more complex
the next thing that you can do for your
model is to add
l1 or l2 penalty to any of the layers
so what's cool about each layer is you
can add
was it the kernel regularizer and then
you can add in a regular
uh a regularization type so they have l1
l1 l2 or elastic net and l2
regularization um in this case i just
did a standard l2
regularization and applied it to two of
the three layers
we basically did two types of
regularization um by basically reducing
the the uh the amount of layers and the
width of the layers while also adding a
l2 penalty and now we can see that our
loss essentially just stabilized um and
this right here i would say is
is fine right um we have consistent loss
it's not expanding and then our
validation actually
is now uh is still pretty stable
and uh we i would say this is this model
is basically done
um again if you're coming from a black
box shallow black box background you
would know that yeah we should add some
type of
l2 or l1 regularization so it's pretty
straightforward
and it's very easy to add because you
essentially just add it as an option in
your layers
so i have an another thing you can do is
if your model
doesn't regularize uh fast enough is you
can add actual dropout
or a layer drop out in between your your
layers
and layer dropout will essentially turn
off some of the nodes
um which will act as like uh to prevent
basically overfitting your model um
and you can try with different rates so
a rate of
0.05 will be it'll switch off
essentially
50 of the um
of the uh the nodes in after that layer
um some people also use uh 0.2 or 20
but generally people use between 50 and
20 for their
dropout so again i i added a layer
dropout
with our l2 penalty and also reduction
of layers
however i did um actually increase the
width to see if i can
increase the performance a little bit
and we can see that it's pretty much
the same thing right here so
we don't we don't have any uh
significant improvement but
that's always something you might want
to add and i think it's also something
people generally do
before they add any type of
regularization for the layers they'll
just add some layer drop out
so one other thing that i wanted to
show you is also batch normalization so
batch normalization
um it's it's pretty much it's getting re
there's a lot of research that goes on
to batch normalization
and it can from what i understand from
just reading some
papers and some research hub is that
batch normalization adds some um
regularization
but it's not really for regularization
but generally it'll try to
the model will train a bit more
efficiently so it's not it's never a bad
thing to add
one thing that um uh i was
i came i was trying to figure out is if
we're adding batch normalization and
also dropout
what what order should they come in and
generally from what i
understand is you you try to have your
batch normalization
before your dropout layer and generally
you want some activation
activation function in between these
layers in between batch normalization
and dropout
so um in this case i added right after
my first densely connected layer i added
some batch normalization
which then goes on to the next layer and
then i add a dropout
and i also added again the l2 penalty
and we can see that the batch
normalization in this case
didn't work very well because we can see
how um what we
would see traditionally is that our loss
would start decreasing to a point
then after a few more epochs it would
start increasing
where again it's overfitting so in this
case i would probably wouldn't use batch
normalization i'd probably switch it out
to a dropout layer
okay and finally one thing that i think
we should always be adding
uh which i kind of forgot sometimes in
my videos is to add
callbacks so in this case i added
um some early stopping um with the set
uh parameter patience equals the 10 so
after 10
epochs is trying to check how much our
validation
um a loss increased or decreased and it
will decide when to stop
additionally what i also added is
callback reduce lr
on plateau so this will basically kind
of slow down
the learning rate of our optimizer
function in this case it's atom
so that could make it a little bit more
fine-tuned with its fitting function
and i think callbacks are very are
really good um however again with
patience you might have to tweak that a
little bit because sometimes it might
just find a little hiccup
uh where it wasn't learning a little bit
for the first like three epochs
and it'll stop fitting but in reality we
might um have we might have gotten more
performance if we let it train for a
little bit longer
so you might have to change patients i
think generally we use
values between like 10 and 5 uh but i
think it's also very domain specific
okay and then finally i just uh
evaluated both all of these models the
overfit model
and all the other regularized models
with the test set
and we can see we have similar um
results
um i will note that our our callbacks
model has a less accuracy additionally
with
our batch normalization model because we
and that makes sense because our
batch normalization model the loss was
increasing so we know that model wasn't
as good as our other
models who had more flatter loss
function loss charts
and then for the uh callbacks model
which has
basically similar accuracy um we can see
that
this model probably didn't um train for
enough
epochs so we might want to increase our
patients on tolerance a little bit more
um so that's basically it for this
week's video um i know this is a pretty
short one
but i want to do a one pre-recorded
another pre-recorded video
um because i'm still in the middle of a
move and i wanted to get a weekly video
out for you guys
so um i will also say that i am planning
on doing
um i'm i am learning more about
geospatial
um analytics and geospatial data science
and stuff like that
and i'm and i want to do a video so
probably at the end of the month after
this video comes out
i will make a video on um geospatial
analysis
and i think uh interesting video would
be to do geospatial analysis on
the 2020 election because we've we found
that it was currently right now we
understand that
um regional differences and specifically
population density has a huge effect on
how
voters vote for each party so i think
that'd be a cool
topic to study but with that being said
i'll see you guys next week and tidy on